okay well here's a question for you guys
then what is the worst show that you
think like what is your guilty pleasure
i guess
if people do you like believe in guilty
pleasures because yeah yeah absolutely i
mean
i you know i mentioned how i got my
friend to watch kiss with me right
i own all 23 volumes of the manga do you
actually yeah why would you fund that
[ __ ] man
because it's so bad yet so good like
it's like it is
i i have a lot of guilty pleasure shows
i'd like to admit but i think
the biggest for me where i can openly be
like yeah i know
this thing sucks but man i can't put it
down it's definitely kisses
there's so many shows i i like that suck
but i wouldn't call it a guilty pleasure
i'm fine with being like yeah i like
that
so you don't believe in a guilty
pleasure or i don't know maybe i've just
gone to the point where i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah that's that's that's my point now i
just like shows
just don't give a [ __ ] anymore i get i
guess i put some shows in different
categories because it's a different kind
of enjoyment because i would never
recommend
i would never like recommend actively
recommend some of these [ __ ] shows
that i watch
but i definitely have some shows that i
put in a like an actual good kind of
enjoyment if there is anything as
like a good kind of uh like a good
enjoyment i mean i say that
this is my guilty pleasure right but i'm
not [ __ ] guilty for working that's
right
it's just my pleasure i'm not guilty
it's just my pleasure
but again like i just call it a guilty
pleasure because i don't
openly be like have you watched this
like i don't openly recommend it unless
you're my friend
unless you're my friend from high school
a yowie scene about to happen
yeah exactly but like you know i have
lots of shows like that like you're also
going to sword is another one
right i still need to watch that i
watched that entire thing and i remember
when dee
was like uh because he because d rebel
house he has this series called the
surviving series
yeah yeah where he goes and like
basically tries to get people to watch
these like absolutely
hot garbage shows and i remember he did
an entire episode on your signature and
i'm just like
bro i'm glad you didn't call me onto
this show because i would have been
praising the [ __ ] out of
the entire time i'm like i know this
sucks i know that there is some
mad wincess [ __ ] going on in this show
but man
it's so good yeah he never called me to
go to go on the domestic girl for an
episode
for good reason because i still love
domestic girlfriend
it's hot garbage the ending sucks would
that be your guilty pleasure
i don't know because i would say the
manga for domestic girlfriend for like
80 of the manga for domestic girlfriend
i still think
it's a [ __ ] well-written show it's
the way i describe it
like it's it's kind of like a soap opera
but the characters are actually well
written in my opinion
but the things that the events that
happen in the soap opera
are still very soap opera stuff but the
way they handle it is still very good
the anime
i feel is that's that's garbage because
that that
that like that skips over a lot of the
actual character development
and like it it basically the anime speed
run [ __ ] so it
the anime just took the trashiest
moments from the manga and put it all in
one package oh well then carnival like
that
i love it yeah it's a speedrun anime
yeah but i like
the the domestic girlfriend manga ending
everyone pretty much agrees it's hot
garbage and i've had time to sit in it
now
and i think i actually like the ending
of domestic girlfriend just because
you're going through the phase that i
had with school days basically
where it's just like the first time you
watched it you're just like man this is
hot garlic but then the more you think
about it you're like you know what
this actually might be genius like
because
i i think the the series started off as
a flaming
dumpster fire yeah and it ended in like
a nuclear fallout kind of
kind of dumpster that's that's good and
he was on theme
you know it was on point like who got it
who got on this
who kind of who got in this train
knowing he was about to crash
and thought he was going to parallel
park
like you know you know what i mean like
we we all we all started watching
domestic girlfriend because we knew it
was a [ __ ] car crash
what were we expecting they let you know
from episode one like literally the
opening scene you were just like oh
this is going to suck this is going to
be messy
yeah and i think the best thing it did
was trick us into
because it tricked us into thinking it
could have ended well because there was
a lot of well-written moments into it
tricked us and they made us forget that
it was a dumpster fire everybody got
enjoyed
man but like well like because of the
way it ended it will forever stick in my
mind
and i will yeah i will i'm i'm gonna
re-read that [ __ ] someday
on his grandkids about that i will tell
my [ __ ] grandkids about the ending of
domestic girlfriend
do you have one like that no not really
i never really like
uh or do you just not even bother with
like shows
that no i feel like with yeah with shows
normally i tend not to i'm trying to
think
would have been some big anime that
ended controversially
but that people didn't know the ending
of already right because of the manga
so it's kind of hard with anime i feel
like yeah i know right so i mean you're
talking about anime original endings now
or like original anime which is that or
if it's or if it's like from like a game
like school days all right like what
about something like darling in the
franks which is the closest okay that
was a fun damn justifier